[Music]
you
hello friends welcome back to the second
lecture on semantic memory now in the
last lecture we discussed what is
semantic memory and how it is arranged
what are the properties of semantic
memory and how long-term memory is
divided into both the semantic type and
the episodic type we also looked at what
is stored in semantic memory the kind of
information facts knowledge is
arithmetic rules certain kind of
information related to everyday world
activities every very world knowledge is
all are stored in semantic memory and so
there is it's a kind of memory which
stores most kind of information that
people use in everyday life we then
discussed a distinction between the
episodic semantic memory and we looked
at what is the main differences and so
some of the main differences I'll repeat
here is that episodic memory is
basically time dependent or temporarily
arranged where a semantic memory is
arranged according to meaning it
basically means that as you are as a
episodic memory unfolds it unfolds in
time you can see yourself in time
whereas if and semantic memory unfolds
it unfolds as a meaning now what do I
mean by this the meaning of this is that
when you unfold in therefore sadiq
memory like let's say you're a prom
night or maybe your graduation night so
every event is are in terms of time from
morning to afternoon to evening what
happened during the whole day whereas if
you ask questions like if you think
about acts like an ethnic rule of how
addition subtraction progresses you
really no need to
no the time the day when you learned out
how they progressed in terms of time the
other differentiation between the
episodic and semantic memory is in
episodic memory it is when so
remembering when it the incident
happened but in terms of semantic memory
it is more about what happened so what
is the content of it and so this is one
distinction between episodic and
semantic memory and so this is the focus
of the memory so episodic memory the
focus is the self so everything arranged
in in episodic memory is around self you
as a person can see everything going
around and you can watch this thing as a
third-person observer but in somatic
memory that's not possible what really
happens is that you get gather
information and you are not the self the
self is not the center stage of this
memory but rather the world knowledge is
the center stage so knowledge is
basically what comes out of semantic
memory so this is something that we saw
in the last class
now we also saw two models of my brief
semantic memory that in the last class
one model was called the hierarchical
semantic Network model where we looked
at how semantic memory our ingest
concepts and a world information and we
saw that it arranges the world
information in terms of nodes so there
are several nodes and so nodes are
basically concepts and these nodes to
nodes which are similar together or
where even if they are dissimilar they
are connected by a pointer or a linked
between them and so this pointer node
kind of a thing which is very similar to
programming in C is what happens in the
hierarchical semantic model
it also looks at looked at some of the
basic interesting facts about cement the
hierarchical semantic model and we also
looked at a criticism of how it doesn't
follow the cognitive economy on how the
concept of hierarchical structure is
basically violated so that kind of thing
is what we saw in the last class we also
saw the feature integration model or the
feature model of semantic memory we saw
that there are two kinds of features so
most information is innate in terms of
features and so there are two basic
kinds of information that is available
with any word concept or knowledge and
so one of these is called the defining
feature that is called the
characteristic feature we also saw a
model of how these features are tested
so that's another interesting thing that
that has to be there so what really
happens is that in the beginning to
start with the feature model takes off
in this way the first at first you start
comparing the characteristic features
and if the characteristic feature of two
objects or a characteristic feature of a
new event is similar to a proposed
concept the more similarity it is the
quicker a person decides the newer
instance to be a part of the concept if
the feature is very low we can go ahead
and say that this particular new concept
which is in front of us this particular
new item which is in front of us is not
a member of the concept and so we can
delete this thing now if the
characteristic feature is neither very
high nor very low so we proceed to
combining or testing the defining
features and so when we look at the
defining features this is the next step
in this case only the defining so if
characteristic features and neither high
nor very low other defining features are
tested and when the defining features we
get a match or the number of defining
features are yes answer comes in then
the
new items or the new entrant is
basically you know matched to the
concept and a yes signal is given or if
the defining features number of defining
features are very low in the new item as
compared to the concept it our new are
and no signal is outputted and basically
it is rejected that the item belongs to
this concept and so this is how the idea
of integration model really works we
also looked at some of the interesting
things about the feature integration
model for example how it progresses and
what are the how it solves the hierarchy
problem or it goes ahead and solves a
category problem so what it basically
says is as category increases more and
more abstraction comes in and so with
the increase in category the or increase
in the size of the category this process
of similarity matching becomes more and
more difficult now in today's class we
look at some of the newer models which
are there so the more models which are
there and then further on we look into
something called how beside the model
the concept of model how is semantic
memory supposed to store information so
we'll start with model proposed by
Collins and Loftus in 1975 and so
Collins and Loftus they basically went
went ahead and they proposed a model
which is very similar to the
hierarchical semantic model and so what
the basic of this model is it's an
elaboration of Pauline villains 1969
model as I said it isn't in extension of
the original model proposed by Collins
and krillen and so basically this model
also states that semantic information or
world knowledge is basically integrated
together or the world knowledge is
stored into the semantic Network in
terms of nodes where nodes is the
concept and pointers the pointers other
links between these concepts
hierarchical model the only change that
this model brings about is that in this
model the concept of spreading
activation
is a is the center point or is the
central feature of this module so then
what does this model basically say the
model conceives our semantic memory as a
network with nodes in the network
corresponding Network corresponding to
concepts so what this model says is that
the semantic memory or semantic
information well information is arranged
in terms of a node on a network of nodes
and so in in this network the nodes
which we are talking about the central
point from which communication occurs
these are called the nodes the nodes are
the concepts and basically the nodes
which stores the basic features of the
concept or the the nodes are always the
superordinate ones superordinate nodes
so concept storing nodes are always the
superordinate nodes also they saw
religious concepts related by connected
in paths of the network so if two
concepts are related together they are
connected by some kind of a pointer or
some kind of a link and this link is
basically called the pointer now the
more similar two nodes are the more
similar two concepts are the higher the
weight between these links so basically
if two concepts are similar they the
path running between these concepts or
the pointer running between these
concepts will have a higher weight then
if two two concepts are connected which
have very dissimilar properties are very
dissimilar features now how do we think
about this so for example let's think
about fire and sunset now both fire and
Sun said they are not connected together
they should not be connected together
because fire relates to some other
concept is some other network and sunset
is related to another network but then
there is one feature of fire and sunset
which are similar and that is that
so one deletion between fire and the
sunset is red but this since they are
not related together the pointer running
between fire and sunset should have a
lesser weight but then if I'm talking
about bread and butter although our king
and queen when I'm talking about king
and queen these two nodes or these two
conner items in a particular Network are
originating from two different networks
but since king and queen are connected
by also through our intermediate network
or intermediary pointer and so each time
when I say a king a queen really comes
in or other ants the in a pair associate
testing the Queen is the answer to king
most of the time for if you ask people
King and then ask them to say the first
word that comes to mind that his queen
is what the transient and what really
happens is these two concepts are
connected by at pointer which has very
high weight similarly pointers
connecting bread and butter or pointers
connecting within shoe and shoe laces
are very high weights then pointers
which are dissimilar - connecting our
desk and an aeroplane so that although
they would be related or they would be
freely related but the pointer which
connects these two nodes or these two
items will be very weakly retained so
that is what this model says the first
further asserted that so in this
particular model is further said that
when one one mode is not activated the
excitation of the node spreads down a
path of links of X related notes so what
happens it is similar to the concept of
spreading activation and so what taking
back from the idea of spreading
activation what this concept says is
that as soon as a node is activated if
sooner than some energy is provided to a
node this energy spreads down through
not only through this node but all
connected nodes all connected links so
if I'm activating the animal node what
would happen is the energy will spread
down to all kind of animals which are
there it could be Birds
it could be mammals it could be reptiles
it could be all kind of animal
and so from there it will further
process down or it will spread down to
other within a million members could
spread down to all kind of members which
are there so it may maybe lion tiger and
so on and so forth in terms of reptiles
it will spread down to snakes to
alligators and to so on and so forth
incomes of birds it will spread down to
different kind of birds whether it is a
feathered word non feathered bird and
soreness so basically this is how the
the idea is what this module says is
that when an energy is provided to a
particular node this energy spreads down
through all connected and Hulk linked
nodes now they this particular theories
or this theorists they believe that as
activities activation spreads down the
path or links to related node so the
exhibition spreads outwardly and
decreases in strength it basically what
it means is that as the node as the
energy it moves down a node what happens
is this energy since its channelized it
gets channelizing to so many other nodes
the energy becomes decrease in strength
so if two nodes are far apart if to
connecting items or two connecting nodes
are far apart from each other in terms
of a number of pointers or fourth or
fifth or sixth level relation and on the
sixth level relation the energy which
starts from the top the node will be
very very decreased so when activation
spreads outward it decreases in strength
and as I said that both aeroplane and
desk are related but they are weakly
related because the energy which is
activated when I say or when I activate
the concept of an aeroplane or any
flying object should be the highest
concept of a Honda which are open bid
fall so when that is activated although
desk will be activated in some way but
the energy spread will be very low
because somehow somewhere they will be
related but since they are so further
out related the weights are very low and
the energy that reaches to desk from an
aeroplane will be
very low and so what they I also say is
that activating related concepts when an
activation sparked from the spreading
activation when any activation or when
in OD energized it activates very
related concepts with with high amount
of energies and distant concepts are our
distant nodes are activated with less
energy that is what is supposed to be
right so nodes which are related
together or semantically or perceptually
or any kind of relations are there
between nodes they would be very closer
together and so when energy when a
particular node when the top node is
energized then similar nodes since they
are very close to each other they will
receive maximum energy but those nodes
which are further apart or which are
very dissimilar to the particular node
in question then the energy which is the
witches which is coming to these nodes
will be very less or it will be very low
so think of this in this way so let's
say that we have a node of animal and so
within animal or let's say I have a node
of living things so I have a top order
node of living things and so within
living things I'll have two or nodes
which are animals and plants and within
animals let's say I'll just cannot put
two categories I'll have mammals
and burped and within plans I'll have
trees and shrubs and so within mammals
I'll further have let's say lion tiger
is one category and the other mammal is
monkey orang utan within words I will
have the feathered words so I will have
something like a parrot and I will have
a non feathered bird so I'll have
something like an ostrich and with it
this also so within trees I'll have an
apple tree or I will have a pine tree
and strap similarly a cellular process
suppose I have a and BS
now what does this model explain and how
does this model quite unexplained so
let's say if living thing is the node
and these are the pointers to the nodes
remember these are the nodes and this is
the pointer which shows the spread of
energy so what it says is when any node
is activated energy spreads down equally
to these nodes right and so when a node
let's say if our node line is activated
now somewhere across this line will be
related to this apple tree or this tree
right some kind of connections would be
there so lion leaves in forests and
forest has trees and so they'll be
connected somehow or other
Saada but what this model particular
says is that when this is energized and
if lion is the node which is energized
and this is how the energy is moving
then concepts which are closely related
together for example lion man
animal and living things they will have
a stronger connection stronger weight
and so more energy will you spread here
or more of them
energy is invested into this node then
further plants although plants are
living things but since the land node
energized and so energy will be spread
to these nodes so birds will receive
lesser energy
similarly the monkey will receive less
energy similarly feathered and non
mother birds will receive less energy
also no question of energy distribution
here a very less energy distribution
here but the most energy distribution
will be to the node lion member animal
and living things and this is what this
module says so if first of all energy
spreads it moves down and it moves down
it spreads out so energy will be
basically moving to all directions right
and so here the less less energy is
invested in these parts then in this
part and this is what the basic
proposition of this module is as I was
talking about so this is how the model
looks like so this is the animal node
this is the bird node this is the
chicken node and so within the bird node
you have the chicken node and so you
look into it so let's say if feet or if
Robin is activated then this particular
node will be energized and so high
energy will be or more energy spent into
this node then the nodes with chicken or
the nodes with ie feathers and so these
are also nodes these are also certain
nodes which are they which are connected
pointer so these nodes will not perceive
and enough sufficient energy but these
these these nodes will they see
sufficient energy and so will these
nodes because they are connected to
Robin also these nodes which are their
legs breathe eyes ears and so on and so
forth
will not be seeing energy and so that is
what the model talks about and this is a
way of it so basically this model is
just an extension of the hierarchical
symmetric model the only difference is
that it talks about this shredding
activation of how energy spreads when it
starts when is activated at the top and
how it filters down or it how it moves
down from there so in this model the
idea is that various
our concepts have many connecting links
and not placed close to each other so
what this model says is that similar
concepts concepts which has certain
features certain distinctive features in
each other they are placed together or
they are blocked in some kind of a block
which are where which have very close
proximity with each other right now on
each link and connection between two
concepts is thought to have a certain
weight or set of weights and now as I
was explaining now since two concepts
are related to each other are they are
placed in close proximity to each other
these links will have very higher weight
so as as two links the more similar two
links are there are more similar two
nodes are the stronger the weight
between them and the more energy or more
energized they become then two nodes
which are dissimilar with each other now
the criticism to this model the
criticism is that the model is the
breadth of the model metal model is so
huge that it is difficult to make clear
and strong predictions from the model
regarding empirical findings so the
model is so huge it talks about that
everything is connected to everything
and there is there's this wait the idea
of weight and the idea of how it is
connected to each other and another
problem with this model is what makes
two concepts similar so this reality
concept or this idea of similarity has
not been explained by this model and so
it's a difficulty it's a genuine
difficulty with this model of how do we
income pass or how do we study this
similarity that we are talking about
what do we call similarity so are we
talking about the defining features are
we talking about the characteristic
features what makes similarity similar
and so this is one thing or one problem
with this model and so in opposition to
this model not exactly direct opposition
to this model
another interesting model was proposed
for semantic memory and this is called
the end essence a CT or a CT our model
so what is this model it was proposed by
John Anderson in semi
1976 and it is called the adaptive
control of thought model of memory it is
also known as a CT a CT star a CTR and
so on and so forth so those of you who
do modeling or who do computational
modeling will be very familiar with the
actr structure the adaptive control of
thoughts no that so basically what is
it's a process model is a process
orientation model and so this process
orientation model basically it's it's
kind of a box pointer model remember the
first class that we did we talked about
two kinds of model the box and pointer
model and we also talked about the
connectivist model where we have unit
input link an output in Kenna and hidden
link so the next model that we talk
about the connectivist model is
basically at that time now this is a box
and pointer model and so what does this
model say so based on analog is two
computers a CT gives rise to several
computer simulations of cognitive
processing in different tasks so
basically this model has certain
conceptualizations of how information in
is stored in our memory basically world
information or common sense information
with implicit knowledge is stored in our
memory so what are these
conceptualization that this modulus is
now the first conceptualization that
this model talks about is that it
distinguishes between the three type of
memory systems it says that the human
memory system is basically arranged in
three different types or three different
ways of looking into it it is arranged
in terms of declarative memories non
declarative memories is that memory
which will have more all information
facts knowledge arithmetic rule world
knowledge everything into it and so
there is no distinction of the episodic
and the semantics here and so this model
looks at declarative memory is the
storehouse of all kinds of information
whether it is personal information
whether it is self related information
or even related information or factor
information so the first
conceptualization of this model is that
there is something called declarative
memory and this declarative memory has
all kinds of information that should be
present or that is present in this world
also there is a conceptualization of
working memory which is information that
is currently at the highest level of
activation so it all talks about working
memory or working memory is that kind of
memory according to a CTR or adaptive
control of thought model which we are
using right now so although declarative
memory stores a lot of information it
has a lot of information and so I'll
explain to you the how this declarative
memory really works
so basically declarative memory is
conceived as a model with nodes it is
similar to the hierarchical semantic mal
model and so there are nodes and these
nodes are connected by weights and these
weights are the determined by the
strength to the pointer or the
similarity between two nodes so
basically that's how declarative memory
store but declarative memory cannot on
its own do anything and so there is a
conceptualization of working memory
working memory is that part of memory or
that kind of memory which is active at
any point of time so when I'm accessing
declarative memory the kind of memory
which is accessing and doing all Carter
alka operations on to declarative memory
is called the working memory it is
memory at the highest level so
information access and information
processing are all all those operations
which are doing the information
processing and accessing memory from
declarative store is basically what is
called the working memory so think of
working memory is a part of declarative
memory but it is that part which is
active which is doing the processing or
which is running the operations or the
rules of the game which which it is
running is what is the working memory
and next to it is the idea of procedural
memory so procedural memory is a kind of
memory which is procedure based but it
works on two or it works something like
in terms of production rules so there
are certain production rules will come
to explain that also so there are
certain production rules there are
certain ways of doing things and the
procedural memory is basically a kind of
memory which follow these rules and does
a particular kind of an act right so
basically then this memory talks about
declarative memory in this way Sanderson
eighty-three believed the declarative
memory stores information in network
that contained notes as I said before
what declarative memory generally tends
to do it has a large vast network and
these
works as concepts which are stored as
nodes and so all concepts which have
similar features a similarity based kind
of matching is there so those concepts
which are similar a clubbed together and
these have the highest weight and they
the weight is basically the strength of
how close two concepts are and so these
have higher weights and they are
connected by some kind of a pointer so
this is how declarative memory is all
about now there are different type of
nodes including those corresponding to
special images and abstract propositions
so basically instead of the
conceptualization of working memory by
allen-bradley very thinks about there is
on something called us visuospatial
sketchpad and phonological loop
Anderson's model talks about declarative
memory as network of nodes and these
nodes are of two specialized very
variation one is spatial image so space
related information and because this
model is a conceptualization of a
computer program so it has to define
spaces and so that one way of looking
into declarative memory is space
information or space images basically
what in in a problem space how does
somebody move so you should have to you
have to know the boundaries of the space
and the kind of problems in a space and
that is why the idea of special image or
space images there so nodes in
declarative memory are of two types
either it is space related nodes which
tell you the boundaries or the kind of
problems or the kind of hindrances that
you get while self solving a problem and
so that is path space relation
information where you have abstract
propositions so abstract propositions
are basically how things are related to
another what is the proposition or what
is the kind of rule which relates to
information together so basically after
abstract propositions are how to rules
are related to each other because these
rules will define how a particular
information is excess so a rule a and
will be how they are related to together
for example let's look at simple row so
if if a if a inverse B and we infer C
which not not
means that seen fuzzy so this backward
propagation is not that and so similarly
these kind of rules of what relates to
what or kind of it's part of a set
theory so how these rules are there how
these prepositions really work is what
is stored in a particular node also a
city model allows for both activation of
any node and first reading activation of
concept so it basically encompasses or
it basically includes activation of node
and spreading activation to be true so
if any node is active the node will pass
this activation on to correlated nodes
and not related nodes together but
related nodes will have high energy and
non related no tree left lower energy
and that that's why it also agrees with
the idea of excitation passing over to
nodes and the idea of what spreading
activation is all about further this
concept the actr
the deductive control of thought it
talks about procedural memory so what is
procedural memory it says representation
of a series of production rules so
basically the procedural memory works in
this way then there are certain
production rules of how an act should be
done now these production rules
generally have a goal it has a starting
a goal and certain kind of conditions a
certain kind of rules to be followed so
basically it goes in this way that if
you start somewhere
now this start and then there is a goal
state also reaching to the goal State
al are basically within the goal state
and the start state are certain
hindrances and certain rules that you
have to follow and if you follow these
rules and overcome these hindrances you
will reach the goal States let's try and
explain to you what the ceiling is so
let's say that it is festival which is
going on and so just near where you live
in your hostel rooms or wherever you
leave the the place near that everybody
is singing in a very good mood but then
you know that there is an exam right so
the idea is that tomorrow you have an
exam you are living where you are living
and just beside the window of where you
are start
in your home lies or in your hostel lyza
program where people are shouting and
marrying together or they are making
merry now the thing is that the goal is
to pass the exam with good marks the
starting point is in a position where
you where you are sitting right now and
then there are rules and there are
hindrances to it the hindrances is if
you are there then basically yeah there
will be so much sound that you cannot
read and the certain and the rules are
that you should not disturb them so you
have to follow a rule the rule is that
certain rules have to be followed so
basically you if there's a lot of people
so you cannot stop them by rule they are
free to do whatever they do but the rule
also says that there are certain
possibilities which are here the
production rule says though there are
certain possibilities here for example
one part one solution to this problem is
going to the library but it also has a
rule so the library starts at 9:00 p.m.
so wait for 9:00 p.m. then follow the
rule of the library where by rule or the
library no man can shout that so even if
people wander when they cannot shout
there and so one way to to reach your
goal is to end to get out or get away
from these hindrances is back you're
back after 9:00 p.m.
go to the library study there till the
rule permits come back and pass the exam
nicely so this way
you have enjoyed till 9:00 p.m. whatever
is happening after 9:00 p.m. what are
their follow certain rules of get rid of
certain obstacles go to the library
which is a solution to it and then pass
the exam and there so this is basically
achieving the goal state following
certain rules and certain hindrances so
basically these production rules or this
procedural memory generally is the
if-then statement which tells how to
perform a particular action so if this
happens then this is the kind of thing
which is there that kind of a thing so
if if you want to study for an exam
together to four years for tomorrow then
you have to find a place which is silent
if you have to find a find a place which
is sound then you have to do this and so
there are certain rules hindrances goals
and four-part system which is they we
will talk about this into
problem-solving into when we come to the
section of problem solving also
production rules specify your goals to
achieve one or more conditions that has
to be true for the rule to apply and one
or more action that results by applying
the rule so as they explain to you there
is a goal to be achieved there are
certain conditions so that should be
fulfilled for example if you go to the
library they could be silent and the
rule says that it has to be silent and
so you have to go there and then these
are the conditions preconditions and
what are more action the action is
getting your books going to the library
starting there and then coming back and
so this is how the conceptualization of
working memory or the idea of actr
really talks about in terms of
procedural memory so basically in terms
of a CTR it's about three memory systems
which interact with each other and they
lead to the formation or storing of
memory data into the human brain now
basically then this is how a simple ACPR
model will work and so you as you see
this is the declarative memory so you
have both the motor module and the
visual module so two modules are there
and these collect information from the
environment the motor model can contain
spatial information the visual module
contains those proposition abstract
propositions which are there and combine
to something called the actr buffers the
actr buffers then also gathers
information from procedural memory
because the procedural memory will tell
you how to exactly go about the
procedure of doing certain things so
basically how to go about the storing
things so declarative memory is these
two parts are the declarative memory and
this information comes to a CGI buffer
the ICTR buffer then talks to procedural
memory which tells you the procedures
which tell you what has to be done and
so the two procedures are pattern
matching and product segregation and
based on that you will come to again to
the actr so this is the input and this
is the output and the output is again
fed to the input and this kind of a
chain goes on and on
so basically any module or any kind of
information which comes here is
processed through this kind of a thing
else this here it is a simple visual
task matching program that have this
and so as you can see this is how this
model really works the actr model really
works now in addition to the actr model
interesting another model which has been
proposed is called a connectivist model
now what is this model it's a very
interesting model and this model doesn't
conceptualize the way we thought about
how things are stored either as networks
or memories or in terms of concepts or
in terms of knowledge network of
knowledge or in terms of three kinds of
memories they don't conceptualize this
in this way
so what connectivist model think about
is that what is stored they say that
what is stored in the memory or what is
stored as word knowledge is basically a
set of changes in the instruction of
neurons which sent to each other
affecting the pattern of activity that
can be constructed from a grave engine
what does it really mean it says that
what is stored
first of all it's it's kind of a copy
from the biological model so as as we
saw in one of these classes I explained
to you how memory stories every stored
as interconnections between neurons and
so what really happens is memory is
basically a connection or it's basically
a path from one neuron to the other
neuron and so what this model says is
that what is stored between two neurons
is not knowledge or concepts now what is
stored in the memory is not knowledge or
concepts it is set of instructions which
are stored and which is passed on from
one neuron to the another what are these
instructions these instructions tell a
particular set of neuron which are
connected to each other to process how
to process data and so there are certain
modes of processing and so these
instructions basically ask neurons are
basically instruct neurons in processing
so let's look at I will briefly define
this model it's a very huge and complex
model so I'll try and very briefly
define this model for you
so basically this model learns to
develop patterns of activation through
many trials which
examples for our example back
propagation so basically how this model
links is how this model really works is
there are certain input layer there are
certain input features or input units
now our unit have has is a pattern is a
unit is thought about as item which
receives input from the environment and
so this unit then passes this
information on to a hidden layer or
hidden unit or hidden related set of
units which are there for example
verifying Robin is a bird it was a very
simple statement organ is a word the
Robin as soon as a Robin unit is
activated it will unit it will activate
all related units with the bird with it
right so things like bird has legs bird
has feathers but has weeks but has a
different color and so on and so forth
so all these units will get activated
now how does this model really work so
it has an input unit and this input unit
when they get an input some of these
hidden and that there is a lot of hidden
layer there is a lot of in hidden input
which is there and so what happens is
the strength of activation or there's a
number of inputs which are there let's
look into this model first of all so
basically this is the connectivist model
of a robin and so this is a lot of
inputs which is coming from the
environment so when you see Robin for
example this is the bird that you are
seeing and so only when Robin is
activated all these things which are
coming from the environment is
deactivated at that point of time only
the robin mode is activated and this
robin mode northern connects to this
hidden layer so robin is so basically if
I am activating the word Robin Robin is
basically a bird and so basically is is
an has this is basically the kind of
connector to robin which can get
activated basically robin is a bird
robin can be a bird robin has a word all
kind of connectors are there and so
robin Easy's activated or can is
activated and so these activations
further link to this
the hidden model or this hidden layer
and the certain layer then basically
gets strained and then from there the
thing is now Robin is a particular name
and kin is also a particular name so
what can Robbie do Robin basically can
be both a bird and a person right and so
when I see a Robin in the environment
the node which is activated is Robin if
I'm saying if this is activated and
Robin can so what can Robin do if it is
a man if it is a human thing it can do
these many things but if it is Robin can
also be an abstract thing and so when it
is an abstract thing it can have several
other features with it but when it is a
bird then it can do all these things it
these nodes are activated because the
bird can grow the word can move the word
can not swim in so this is not activated
the bird cannot sing so it is not
activated maybe it should activate the
word cannot bark and so this is not
activated the bird doesn't have branches
and so it is not activated so when a set
of input node is activated these input
nodes has a number of connecting nodes
with it right so when when I look let's
assume an example where I look outside
of my window and when I see several
things I put my attention on to Robin
now this Robin has a bird is a bird and
so there are certain features of Robin
which has to be activated and so
basically this model then say is that if
Robin is activated similarly we will be
activated the word can Robin can and
Robin can do what so you see a Robin or
you see a bird which is on the on on
where your attention is followed but
there are several other things which are
there so there will be several other
nodes which can get activated but your
attention is focused on two only Robin
and so what Robin can do is it can grow
it can move it can fly and these three
things are the only one which should be
activated but could also be activated
but then other things are related to all
other things that you have seen in the
outside environmental world and so
basically it will not get activated now
how does this model really work so this
model says is that the input layer
basically it learns so when an input
layer is activated it activates related
layers
related hidden lanes with it and so it
at the beginning of any input cycle the
strength between the input node and the
hidden node will be random weights let's
say if zero and one of the two allowable
weights which the input layer and the
hidden layer would have at the beginning
of any propagation or the beginning of
any input signal the weights between the
hidden layer and the input layer would
be 0.25 now as as I said there are a
number of factors or the number of items
which compete with each other to start
the input and since Robin has started
the input it will change its weight
right though so the weight of Robin will
become 0.8 from zero point five will
become zero point eight but all other
weights for example tree house all other
things which have been captured at the
same moment but attention has not been
put to the weights of these will change
slowly change to 0.2 0.3 0.1 why 0.15 or
so on and so forth only the robin node
is activated so the weight of this will
increase which will increase to one zero
point eight and so the in hidden layer
will learn this now then there will also
get some information both from the
perceptual system as well as from the
memory system because robin is activated
so the memory system will also feed in
some information and so for example
robin can Robin has Robin kind of a
thing so it is present tense and so can
would be activated and so can will have
a higher weight it will the weights will
change to 0.8 and similarly there are
certain features of what Robin can do
now Robin can fly it oven can has a weak
it it can do this it will do sing it can
have color and all those things will be
activated in all other ways will not be
activated now basically this model then
what it does is from an input it
generates an output and with that
input/output system it starts learning
right and so well how it what is the
meaning of learning each time a
particular input is selected and output
is generated the connection becomes
stronger and stronger more stronger the
connection the more faster the learning
is
this kind of model basically is a
learning model so let's look at what
this is and so this how do we train this
model so first you show the model that
Robin is whatever it is to anybody you
show the model any but it can do these
things and they can basically result in
this kind of a feature and so it is a
training example from that training
example show it the model a bird now you
have started with the idea of bird so
from Robin change it to parrot and
that's how the model behaves now parrot
is very similar to la Robin so as soon
as it identifies it is closer to the
concept Robin so it will then adjust the
bait between it and the when the the
input system and the hidden system as
0.8 it will learn this and similarly
output all the features that will output
for the concept a bird and it goes on
doing this and so our training after
training or time after time it will then
develop that this is the feature of what
should be of a bird so next time you
present it a bird that it doesn't know
which is not a training example it
quickly classifies this as a bird and
then outputs an list of features that
the bird is going to happen so initially
connections between nodes are set as I
said you said a set at random weights
experience leaves these connections to
be activated more and less strongly so
the more closely each time when it
produces an output this output is
compared to a set of truth features this
output is connected is basically matched
to what should be what should be
expected as an output and the closer the
match the better their training so if
it's not closer then the model model
adjusts the weights accordingly and we
either delete some of the features or
increases some of the features and this
goes on making the weights or the goes
on making the number of connections so
training occurs by presenting a specific
example to the network with there
generates a particular output so you
start with let's say parrot and you
teach the model then if parrot occurs if
parrot comes in these are the features
you need to output next time you start
the training with say a sparrow this is
what it is so slowly the more model or
Scalia the input layer will understand
that ok once something like this is
presented something like a bird is
presented with
gathers those features then these are
the nodes which has to be activated and
so the nodes which have to be activated
then where there's a higher weight and
then the output which it which it should
present so also tell it the output so
when I show a parrot show me the output
that it can fly and wing it has wings it
can do this it can do that that kind of
a thing and also show me the weights for
things it cannot do and so match it with
this idea that parrots can fly so this
is a verified sentence and this is a
true sentence so verify with that now
the next after so many trials after say
50 or 100 trials when you show it may be
a different kind of bird for example
let's say crow and what does the model
do when you show it a crow although you
do not tell the model this is a crow the
model adjust the weights accordingly and
says that it has a beak it can fly and
so on and so forth because these are the
pruning programs so you train it with
some examples and then the model learns
on its own and starts adjusting the
weight so it will also give you with the
crow it will also give you inputs
outputs like it is black in color it has
two eyes beaks these are the generic
things but certain other features also
it will tell you also training placing
epochs so basically these trainings they
go about in epochs and each epoch
produces an output activation which is
compared to a correct target activation
this is how this model really works and
as I said there's a number of things are
there's a number of input systems which
are activated only robin is activated
and so what will happen is only these
connections are energized and all
connections have starts having lower
weights and so since this feature is
related to this feature so these
features add on to this model and so
only ABC as you can see is activated
here and others are not and so when it
gets training then in the next training
round on the next epoch it will also
learn that it is a bird it will also
learn that it is red or green in color
it is also along that it it has wings
and feathers and so on and so forth and
some more number of outputs will be
activated so it is not only that through
these models we can explain semantic
memory there are two more concepts
through which we can understand how
semantic knowledge or world knowledge is
Eirene and so toward these concepts one
of the famous ways of doing that is what
was proposed by Sir Frederick Bartlett
and so what Bartlett did was he's read a
very interesting study and he showed
that there is a lot of reconstruction in
memory and this reconstruction is how so
what he says is that what semantic
memories stores is not an exact
representation of what happens but a
gist a kind of a broken down version of
the information that is what is stored
in our memory and so he in his
experiments he presented something
called a war of ghosts a story to one a
couple of people and the story was a
complex story it had many relations and
many kind of information into it they
were so interfaced and they were so
closer to each other that was very
difficult to break the story apart and
so this story was presented to a number
of people and when these people who were
presented they were asked to recall the
story after a certain period of time but
what really happened is that most of the
people remember the gist of the story
the main idea of the story but they
forgot the basic features are the basic
some basic things about the story for
example names places these very mixed up
but the story the outline the story was
what was there in Frederick that partly
says it there is a way of storing these
kind of information agenda involve
knowledge information and that is what a
schema is so then look at what is a
schema so basically schema represents
knowledge in the semantic memory that's
what what les proposition is there is
something called a schema so what is a
schema then a schema contains general
knowledge about the world and
information about particular events so
it's not only consisting of general
knowledge about world but it also has
information about particular even so it
has both declarative as well as
schematic semantic type of information
onto it
now schemas are large units of organized
information which are used for
representing concepts situations events
actions in memories so basically a
schema is kind of a huge it's a huge box
kind of a thing where a lot of
information could be presented into or
could be put into and these information
when they are put into they sort of act
together or they sort
work together for example rumelhart and
oourtney in 77 they propose that the
fundamental building block of cognition
is this schema so this schema has
information stored into it into all
kinds of and world knowledge it's kind
of a guideline of what should happen a
schema is kind of a guideline or what's
to be expected for example the schema of
let's say a village now the schema for
village basically says that these things
for example bollocks
feels Greenfield use water bodies people
farmers trees animals this is what
should you expect in a village you
should not or you can not expect a car
or modern build building or an aeroplane
in a village and so these are the kind
of things which is expected with the
kind of which is not expecting the
schema for village will have this kind
of an information so basically then
schemas are big packets of information
that contains both a variable in a fixed
part for example if we look at the
schema of a dog the fixed part of this
information is that it has mammals in
four legs because the fixed part is sad
across all the instance of the schema so
any dog we look into it it will be a
mammal and it will have four legs but
then most Chema's also have a variable
part and the variable part is where we
wear this feature they change across
instances or change across variations of
the schema and so things like breed
things like size color temperament these
mice change the curd dog so you might
have an Alsatian you might have a
chameleon you might have a scent Bernard
or you can have any kind of dog which is
there you could have a very light
tempered dog a heavy tempered dog a
highly colored or non colored dog a
Chihuahua kind of a thing which has a
very strange kind of a thing sizes so as
I said you can have great dane which is
very high in size you can have a
chihuahua which looks like more like a
cat and so on and so forth so within dog
variations could be there but then the
fixed part is that all dogs have are all
dogs within that particular category or
that sistema should be same also schema
indicates relationship among various
parts of information now what what do I
mean by this
if I'm talking about a dog now the idea
is that the dog should have a head and
this head should have two eyes only the
tail should not be coming out of the
head and or the nose so basically there
are certain relations which are there
among certain parts of the dog and that
is what it is so the rear of the log
should have the tail and the forward of
the dog should have eyes and the color
of the dog should be in this variation
the hind leg should be here the fore leg
should be here this kind of
interpretation should be there so Sigma
indicates the relationship among the
various pieces of information should be
there what is the fixed piece and what
is the variable piece and what is the
relation to each other so a dog which
has our legs coming out of the eyes is
not actually your dog an instance of a
dog but a dog which has eyes coming out
of the head is basically a kind of a dog
and so this is the relationship and so
the leg should be below the eyes and so
on and so forth all school schemata
connects to other schemata in a
varieties of ways so not just one schema
a number of schemas can be connected to
each other one schema of particular
thing can also be connected to on the
schema of some other things now schema
is also used for filling or in default
values of certain aspects of a situation
which help us in making an assumption so
basically the schema tells us as I said
the schema tells us what is to be done
in a particular situation so let's say
if you are in in in an exam hall the
schema says that or if I am telling you
a story of how I met my roommate school
class roommate for the first time I do
not need to tell you that what is my age
because most people turn to school
around 18 19 years in a graduation
school around 18 19 years so this can be
auto-filled
that this is what your age should be and
so when I am talking when referring to a
friend as her you know I need to tell
the gender of this fail so this can be
auto-filled
a schema will provide this kind of a
thing so when I was talking about a
gender I am talking about that my
roommate is a her then the idea that
this is a female is automatically comes
in also schema exists in all levels of
abstraction thus they can exist for
small parts of knowledge also
so basically what it means is that
schemas can be for very small knowledge
abstractions for example certain letters
written in certain kind of ink letters
or it could be the schema could also
exist for greater details for example
like the theory of relativity so there
are certain schemas in the theory of
relativity for example the fabric of
time the idea that time dilation happens
the idea that there is something called
the space-time where space means time
and then this variation so those schemas
and also very small schemas of how
certain letters can when combined with
each other
give us a perception of a different
letter so that basically our that level
of abstraction also schema should work
so write in this way and it becomes a B
or mean this a you have seen those
letters right Kelly graph is of certain
kind of letters and so they also are a
certain level of scheme identification
now related to the idea for schema is
the idea of a script now script a ski
mask for routine events for example
going to a restaurant what is a script
think of it in this way when you go to a
restaurant there is basically four part
meal system right you start with the
soup or some kind of a beverage to start
with then there is the first course then
there is the main course then there is a
suite and then you wash your hands you
pay the bill and you move away and so
basically this is what the script is the
script says how the schema moves in time
how the schema moves across so what is
the production rule for a schema or what
is the procedure of a schema or what is
the procedure for routine event is what
our script is all about
now scripts are used across a variety of
situations for filling out unknowns for
example let's say that I visit a new
city right so I visit some some city I'm
the Luminess am sitting in am living in
India and I go to the US now when I go
there I did not think what a restaurant
should be in how to sue the restaurant
function because I know from India that
this is how a restaurant functions so
most rational restaurants would function
in the similar way it's not that in
those days friends something else will
happen the same idea of what I have in
India should be a capture of an incident
there and so scripts certainly help us
in organising information or filling up
information or basically how we can use
it in different
scenarios schemas also scripts also help
us in making a number of inferences now
what do I mean by that when I say that
you have you can get a number of
inferences so a particular script when
define it shows you that what is the
result of this particular thing so if a
main course is there what is the result
of this main course in a dinner
what is the result of the or what
follows for example so if I say that I
went to the restaurant and I ate ate my
food and I came back basically you feel
in your head that you might have paid
the bill and that then you came back and
so this feeling of information that you
arrive the restaurant with someone went
into the restaurant sat at a place when
I say that I ate food in a restaurant
today
basically the all other ideas of you
sitting in a restaurant having ordering
the food eating itself is filled up and
so they this information this inferences
can be made from it that you are paid
the bill and come and you not run away
from things the restaurant did come out
and so these inferences can be and also
lastly schemas help us in making an
order and so to this to test this
particular thing how schema makes us the
things perceive things in order
this baauer black and Turner they need a
particular study and so in this study
what the leaders do is presented a story
and in this story the story was made in
such a way that there were several
concepts in the story and they were in
unordered form so some parts of the
story
the climate's of the story came before
and the meaning of the story was in the
somewhere in the middle and the middle
of the story was somebody in the back
and that kind of information was
presented to people nobody when I recall
was done most people remember the story
in the right correct procedure in the
right scripted order so although the
scripts was deviated people remembered
it in the right way from how it began -
what was the climax - what was the
middle part - what was the climax and
how it ended right so no matter if
intermix the kind of sequences of a
story or sequences of a particular event
a routine event this schemas or this
scripts will basically help us reorder
these things together so basically what
we did in today's class is we looked at
some other models of
semantic memory or world knowledge
memory into it how do they work and what
are the pitfalls of this model criticism
of this model we also source the
connectivist model which is a very
interesting model so if you are looking
up for taking up computational modeling
you can either use a CTR or connectivist
modulus and these models are interesting
models of how they product because these
models are also used for generating
artificial intelligence systems or
learning systems so basically that's
what we discussed there and then from
there we also looked at another way of
storing information in terms of scripts
and schemas and so this brings us to the
end of this lecture thank you
[Music]
you